[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN PAGANO:
Project-thinking rewards
doing the minimum to meet
the project's specifications,
the project's scope, and not
screwing up while doing it.
And it's not very
customer-focused, right?
Your focus when you're
working on a project
is to succeed by the minimum
standards of the project,
and most often you're never
even talking to a customer.
But that's not even
the worst part.
That's not even
the biggest issue
of why I get upset
when we talk about--
when I say stop
thinking about APIs
as projects is that projects are
planned work with an end date.
An end date-- like,
APIs drive mobile.
They drive web.
They drive IOT, all the smart
cars, all the smart appliances,
your smart vacuum cleaner.
All these things--
that's not going away.
That's only getting bigger
and bigger and bigger,
a huge part of our
lives, the main core
part of how we do business.
So why would that
have an end date?
That doesn't make
any sense at all.
So when I come and visit you
folks at your various offices
and you tell me
that you're thinking
about becoming
API-centric, you're
thinking about
becoming a platform,
doing some digital
transformation,
you always ask, Brian,
what's the big mistake?
Like, you've seen people do
this all around the world.
What's the one big mistake
that we're likely to make?
And the fact that you're tuned
in to a session like this,
the fact that you're
asking the question,
means you might not
make that mistake.
But the big mistake I see
is passing the potato.
You're all wondering
why I'm showing you
a potato in the
middle of the workday,
it's because when you take the
hot potato and you pass it.
So when I say to somebody,
let's talk about APIs,
they say, oh, let
me have you talk
to my director of operations.
Wait a minute.
I definitely should talk to
your director of operations
at some point,
just like I should
talk to your architects,
developers, security.
But we're talking about
market share here.
We're talking about revenue.
We're talking about your brand.
We're talking about your partner
ecosystem, your developer
ecosystem.
These are serious
high level topics.
These aren't
operational concerns.
And why does this happen?
It's because APIs sounds geeky.
I wish there was a
way that we could
have these conversations without
even using the word "API."
Because it does.
It sounds super
technical, super geeky,
and there's obviously a deep
technical component to it.
But APIs are so
much more than that.
Now, OK, Brian, if
they're not a project--
if you're telling us stop
thinking of APIs as a project--
then what are they?
How should we think about APIs?
Well, let's think about
that for a second.
APIs might be a program.
We all know what a program
is, a cluster of projects.
So this is better.
If I come to visit your office
and you say, hey, Brian,
I want to talk to you
about our API program,
I'll be a little happier.
Because that shows that
you're thinking about it
in broader terms
that you recognize
that this is technology
that you can leverage
across multiple
lines of business,
across multiple projects.
That's great.
Another possibility
is a platform.
One slide that I
often like to show
is talking about the
most valuable companies
in the world today versus, say,
25 years ago, 15 years ago.
If we look at the most
valuable companies in the world
from 15 years ago, 25 years ago,
it's all the usual suspects.
It's all the people
you'd expect--
your giant petroleum
companies, General Motors,
the big industrial companies.
And if you look at the most
valuable companies in the world
from last year, it's
Apple and Google Alphabet
and it's Microsoft and
Facebook and Amazon.
And always people say,
oh, Brian, I get it.
It's Silicon Valley companies.
Wrong.
I mean, yeah, they all are
Silicon Valley companies.
But there are a lot of
Silicon Valley companies
that aren't on that list.
OK, Brian, I get it.
They're all software companies.
Wrong.
I mean, yes, they are
all software companies.
But there's a lot of
software companies
that aren't on that list.
If you look at the most
valuable companies in the world,
the thing that
you'll immediately
notice that they
all have in common
is that they're all platforms.
That means they allow
other people outside
of traditional
organizational boundaries
to participate in their success.
Now, this is very,
very powerful,
because this is no longer
a hypothesis or a guess.
This is now empirical
evidence of how
you succeed in the
21st century, which
is very different from how you
succeeded in the 20th century.
We all learned
how to do business
by raising barriers to entry
instead of lowering barriers
to cooperation, which is how
you win in the 21st century.
That is a pretty big shift.
And again, while some of
this can seem semantic,
think about the 1,000
decisions that your company
is going to make this month.
If you're making them
on the 20th century
model of raising
barrier to entry,
versus the 21st century
model of becoming
a platform, of lowering
barriers to cooperation,
that's going to result in
a very different outcome
for the success of
your company, possibly
the survival of your company.
Now, APIs might be a program.
That might be a platform.
I'd be quite
pleased if I came in
and you wanted to talk to me
about your platform project,
turning your business
into a platform.
Because honestly, if you're not
creating a digital ecosystem,
or participating
in an ecosystem,
you probably only
have a couple of years
to continue doing business
in your current form.
Now, that can mean a
lot of different things.
And I don't mean to
sound too gloomy,
but this is the reality
of today's market.
Now, the third
possibility of what
an API is if it's not a
project is a way of life.
APIs might just be
the kind of thing
that become ubiquitous in
our business and technology.
Now, why would I say that?
Obviously I love APIs.
I have the sticker on my
laptops and the sticker
on my briefcase.
And I dream about this
stuff when I'm at home.
But APIs power
customer experience.
And the second big mistake I see
most companies making today--
most of these big traditional
powerhouse companies when I
come to visit your office is--
is that it's so inwardly
focused and so focused
on your existing data centers,
your existing technologies.
And the battle right
now is on the front end.
The battle is about
the experiences.
Now, the people on the front
end may be your employees.
It doesn't have to be customers.
It's often customers.
It can be a point of
sale people at stores.
It can be your partners and your
supply chain, your employees,
any one of these people.
They are demanding a
better customer experience,
because we're all
doing business in 2018,
whether we want to or not.
We can't say we're not ready.
And doing business in 2018
means that everybody expects
you to get to market faster.
That means that they
expect self-service.
They expect you to be on the
platforms on which they're
happiest and most productive.
We've all been trained
to expect these things,
and there's really
no way out of it.
And yet, I see so many
companies still focusing
on eeking an extra 5% of
performance out of the backend
and not focused on delighting
their users with great customer
experiences, like APIs
would help them to do.
APIs also enable the
ecosystems and platforms.
I just talked about
how essentially,
empirically the way to
win in the 21st century
is to become a platform or
to participate on a platform,
to become an ecosystem or to
participate in an ecosystem.
There really is no other answer.
And it just so happens that
APIs are a fantastic way
to allow your company
to do these things.
Now, APIs drive
revenue and growth.
Think about it.
If you could suddenly
get your apps
onto a bunch of new devices,
just statistically speaking,
you have a bigger
addressable market.
If you can make changes
faster, if you can say yes
to more partnerships-- that
old kind of Hollywood model
where they make 10
movies, and eight of them
lose money, and the ninth one
breaks even, and the 10th one
is a blockbuster and pays
for the next 10 films.
The problem is they don't
know which one that is,
so they have to make
the next 10 films.
Partnerships and technology
experiments in the company
can feel that way, that
most of them lose money.
Most them aren't worth
the time and effort.
What if there was a
self-service platform?
What if there was a technology
and a methodology that
would help us to just say
yes to every partner who
comes and says, we'd like to do
some business together and see
which one is the blockbuster.
And if you say yes to every
10, statistically over time,
you're going to discover
new revenue streams.
You're going to discover
that your business has
a bunch of exciting new
partnerships and products that
really would never
have come organically
from inside the organization.
Now, whenever we have
new folks starting
at Apigee, and especially
like a new PR firm or somebody
wants to understand,
Brian, what's
the reason why so
many of our customers
buy the Apigee product?
And I say, there's a lot.
There's security, and scale,
and ease of use, and experience.
I mean, there's a
lot of good reasons.
But I think fundamentally,
it comes down to speed.
Every CIO I talk to, every CTO
I talk to around the world,
without fail, says,
the business is crazy.
They're asking me to move faster
than we've ever moved before,
to release on multiple
platforms simultaneously.
We're just, frankly,
not set up for that.
And every time I talk to the
CMO, they say my IT is broken.
They're too slow.
They're too expensive.
And they keep saying
no to everything.
So what if there were a
technology and a methodology
like APIs that would allow you
to decouple those two worlds?
That's what APIs
do, fundamentally,
is to help you move
faster to allow each side
to move at its own speed.
You've heard two
speed IT, and that's
a somewhat judgment-laden term.
But you get the
idea, that each end,
the front end and the back end,
can move at their own pace.
APIs are a perfect
tool for enabling that.
So, OK, that's starting
not to sound so geeky.
We talked about why this often
that hot potato gets passed,
because this sounds like
a really geeky topic.
But if we're talking
about customer experience,
our customer
satisfaction, they're
not eroding our market
share, holding off
some of our disruptors or
traditional competitors,
if we're talking about
participating in an ecosystem,
our business itself
becoming a platform
and becoming one of those
winners in the 21st century
like we looked at before, if
we're talking about something
that may contribute
to revenue and growth
and something that's going
to help us move faster
so that our customers
are happier,
our employees are happier, and
as IT, the business gets off
our backs and says, OK,
you guys are delivering
exactly what we
need you to deliver,
that doesn't sound so geeky.
That sounds really important.
And hopefully you'll
see that those
are the kind of conversations
we should be having when we come
and visit.
Now, philosophy, logic,
a bit of a hobby of mine.
So I like the idea of
a category mistake.
And for those who don't
know, a category mistake
was an idea created by the 20th
century philosopher Gilbert
Ryle.
He was at Cambridge or Oxford.
I can never keep
those two straight.
Let's say it was Cambridge.
And he took his friend
to visit the university
and showed them the dining
hall and the dormitories
and the lecture
halls and all that.
And the friend said,
this is all great.
Where's Cambridge?
So the friend had made
a category mistake.
They thought Cambridge
was a type of building,
and Cambridge is a
type of university.
It's a very powerful
tool to understand where
companies are making mistakes.
So companies are making
a category mistake
by thinking that some
business-level catalyst,
something that affects customer
satisfaction, that affects
revenue, that affects
partnerships, that affects time
to market, is somehow
an operational issue.
This is so mind blowing to
me that I often think of it.
It's like saying that,
well, our company's revenue,
it's really mostly a
pencil-sharpening issue.
I mean, it's the
operational aspect there
of sharpening that pencil.
Of course not.
Sharpening that
pencil has nothing
to do with your
company's revenue.
That is a complete
category mistake.
But how does this happen?
So, when I was a technology
executive in New York,
my teams would often come to me.
They'd come into my
office in the morning
and say, Brian, that
guy is being a jerk.
And I'd say, I don't think so.
I don't believe it.
I mean, it was Wall Street.
It's possible.
But I don't believe anybody
woke up this morning,
looked in the mirror and said,
I'm going to be a jerk today.
So we need to find
some other explanation
for what's going on.
This person thinks that their
mandate is such and such.
And they think they're
executing against that mandate.
So maybe they don't understand
the scope of their job.
Maybe they don't understand the
priorities of the organization.
There's some other motivation,
I think, than just being a jerk.
Now, we know that some
of the miscommunication
happens because
APIs sound geeky.
But every organization
has blind spots.
And just like I was talking
about the folks coming
into my office in New
York, I notice there's
a lot of miscommunication.
On the one side, we have
business which is obviously
trying to do the
right thing, keep
everybody gainfully employed,
delight the customers.
And on the other side,
you've got technology,
which is trying to do
what it's supposed to do,
which is prevent breaches, make
sure that disaster recovery
and business
continuity are covered,
audits, all these great things.
So you have two smart groups of
people who are both competent,
trying to do the right
thing, and yet, we
end up in the situation
we're in today,
which is, it takes us too long
to get new things to market.
Our customers aren't happy.
We're not on all the devices.
The apps aren't as good as
some of the startup, you know,
flashy apps.
How can we not get this solved?
And that's because there's
this chasm where there's
a language and a process
barrier between these two worlds
and everybody thinks they're
saying the same thing.
And yet, it's not
resulting in the positive.
So I was told a few years
ago a story of the CEO of one
of the major world airlines who
was flying for whatever reason
on a competitor's flight.
They didn't have a route
that flew that way.
This was several years ago.
He noticed that they had
media controls in the armrest.
And he said, this is fantastic.
We have to do this
for our customers.
And he landed, and he
called up his lieutenants.
And he said, you
know, we have to make
these things for our customers.
And so this trickled
through the organization.
Let's put media
controls on the armrest
to delight our customers.
And what do you
suppose happened?
Each group started
saying, well, we
can use the existing arm rest.
We'll just drill a hole
underneath and kind
of superglue a little
panel in there.
And you guys all remember
this from a few years ago.
Where you'd fall
asleep on an airplane,
and it's like a gravity well.
Your arm would get sucked in.
It would start to fall asleep
and tingle in really bad ways.
Your elbow would always
hit the volume button,
things like that.
It was miserable.
And if you think about a
plane with 300 people on it,
you're talking months of
person hours of misery
being added to every flight.
And the goal was, you recall,
delight our customers.
But it got mistranslated
as it passed
through the organization.
And some people heard
that as, save money.
Some people thought that meant,
let's be as clever as we can,
reusing existing parts.
It got all good
people all trying
to do something
that they thought
was the right thing to do.
And yet it resulted in misery.
Fortunately, we have gone
to the touch screen era.
We're not really
doing that anymore.
As a very frequent flyer,
this is great for me.
But this to me
starts to explain how
we have two different
worlds and how we can end up
in this crazy situation.
Now, I know it
can sound like I'm
saying a lot of doom and gloom.
But let's talk about
some good news.
There is a way to solve this.
I know there's a lot
to look at when we're
looking at all the other things
other than simply deploying
a technology, configuring a
technology, when we're talking
about governance and funding
and all these various bits that
go around it that just
kind of have to be done
and are very important
to getting things done
but they're not the
cool technology bits.
If you look at the
problem domain--
so this is the third
big mistake that I
see companies making,
is they try to solve
one sixth of the problem.
And I don't get that at all.
You guys have a bunch of stuff
that you've built and bought
over the years.
You have an end user-- often
a customer maybe an employee--
on the other side.
If you can't get from
point A to point B,
you have not solved the problem.
And so my mind is blown all the
time when people come and talk
to me.
Well, we found a vendor that
will sell us a developer web
site.
Great.
You need a developer website.
It's necessary.
It's not sufficient.
I mean, what happens when
they start building apps?
What happens when traffic
starts flowing through?
Don't you need scale and
security and monetization,
all these other things?
Or my ESB vendor or
somebody on the back end
has allowed me to
do some exposure.
Great.
Exposure is not the problem.
And a runtime is critical.
It's necessary, but
it's not sufficient.
What about all the
developer tools?
What about analytics?
What about all the other pieces?
You've got to get
from point A to point
B. That's the problem domain.
And of course, the players.
Who's involved in this?
Now, the problem domain
can be easily visualized,
as I said, from all
the stuff you've built
and bought all the way
out to the end user.
It says customer here,
but just any end user.
And I think you'd agree
with me that if you don't
get from point A to
point B, you simply
haven't solved the problem.
And that's why it's
so confusing to me
when people talk
to me about solving
one sixth of the problem.
It makes no sense.
Now, we know the players that
are involved in this too.
So I said, if you can identify
the entire problem domain
and identify who
the players are,
it starts to make more sense.
Because some people
think, oh, no.
They're cookie lickers.
You know that idea,
like, when you were 10
and you didn't
want your siblings
to get one of the cookies,
so you lick all the cookies
so nobody else can eat one.
This happens in organizations
all the time too.
I'm going to lick this
cookie, and this is my cookie
and no one else gets the play.
So it's good to get
on the white board,
on the screen, whatever,
who is involved here,
who are the other players.
Another way to look at it, a
more abstract way is to say,
OK, we've got lines of
business and generally
in a federated
technology organization,
they've got a line
of business tech.
But we've also got
the brand, and we've
got enterprise technology.
And there's usually a kind
of an unhealthy tension
between these two things
when fundamentally they
all want the same thing.
And I've been very
pleased to see
how much APIs tend to reduce
this tension between these two
groups.
So since APIs are just going to
be part of how we do business
and live our lives from
now on, like water to fish,
it's just going to be
ubiquitous in how we live.
Think about how to
streamline governance.
So I know some people are
very extreme in their view
that APIs make
governance go away.
I don't believe that
coming from Big Fortune
500 companies myself.
I think that it does
streamline governance.
I think a RESTful API,
just by necessity,
needs less governance
than an old fashioned soap
contract would, for example.
To think about, it's
the classic debate
of who funds these things.
The groups that are
going to benefit
most from their consumption, or
the backend teams themselves?
I mean, think
about realistically
how we can fund this better.
Because I talk to so many
organizations when we come in
and help them.
And it turns out that they feel
like they can not do business
as a brand or across
whatever organizational trust
boundary, whether that's
a department, division,
line of business, whatever.
But APIs give you
this abstraction layer
and say, I don't really care
how they implemented this.
I don't really care
what a customer
looks like in their database.
I don't even truly need
a single source of truth.
We've now got an interface
that all of our developers
know how to use, all of our
architects know how to use.
And now we can go forward
and do clever things
like the commercial models
to say, how could we
charge differently now?
Could we now have
subscription offerings?
Could we do revenue sharing?
Could we do advertising
based stuff?
There's a lot of
different ways to make
money that might not have
been available to you
before you became API centric.
So APIs, in my
experience, tend to be
a forcing function for an
organization and the secret--
that's why it's not in tiny
print, it's in big print--
is that the challenge
won't be technology.
This technology-- just the
Apigee platform itself,
for example, as one example--
it just has billions
and billions
of calls going through it.
It's fourth
generation technology.
The technology is
well and truly solved.
It's the other bits
of the organization.
Can we switch from being
a 20th century company
to a 21st century mindset?
Can we start thinking
in terms of not
being reduced to
blindly following
our governance and our
existing processes but think
about customer delight, think
about that problem domain
and how we can work
together to solve that?
So how do we start
doing that, Brian?
That all sounds great.
That's like a
performance report where
your boss says, do better.
That's not very actionable.
You can't do much with it.
So I would say, hey, you
can start with a single API.
You've got to start somewhere.
Try to make it a key API.
When I work with retail
companies and say,
we'll start with
a store locator,
I think, you know,
no one's going
to get fired if the
store locator fails.
That's not critical path.
You need to do something that's
going to be critical path.
Recognize that an operational
aspect will exist.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, Brian,
you've been telling us
the whole time--
this isn't an operational issue.
That's a category mistake.
Right.
It is a category
mistake, but that
doesn't mean there's not an
operational aspect to it.
And it would be just
as foolish to ignore
the security, the
day-to-day operations,
and try some new things.
People ask me all
over the world,
what makes Silicon
Valley so different?
You've worked in New York.
You've worked in Europe.
You know, what makes
things so different here?
And I think one of
the big key factors--
it's just my opinion--
is that in Silicon Valley
it's OK to fail.
In fact, failing
fast is a good idea
and gives you data that you
wouldn't get any other way.
It gives you a tremendous
amount of data.
Now, when I was in
New York, I often
felt like if I had a big
marquee project that failed,
it might torpedo my
career at that company.
That might be enough to
stop my forward advancement
at that company.
And that's simply not
the case out here.
And I encourage people to
try to adopt that mindset,
that nobody gets an API
right on the first try.
Nobody.
You're usually going to
rev it at least three times
the first year.
So be OK with that.
APIs, they're a facade.
So they're not
heavy and expensive
like a backend system.
And people seem to have
trouble making this mind shift.
No, it's OK to experiment
and prototype with APIs.
So one of the things we do to
understand this market better
and to help our
customers understand
themselves better is we have
this tool called Compass.
You can find it at
compass.apigee.com.
And it's a series
of questions that
help basically to assess
the digital maturity
of an organization.
Now, most of the folks that
will be listening to this,
you are the ones
who already get it.
You're the ones
who already know.
But you probably have
a lot of colleagues
around your organization
who don't get it,
who wonder why it's not
still OK-- you know,
we did business like
this in 20th century.
And it made us very successful.
And you know, why
would we change that?
Or, you know what?
We don't need help.
We are already digital.
We're already transforming.
We are already
doing these things.
And so what we found
is it's actually likely
that some people in
your organization
are saying the right
words, that somebody
is producing some kind of vision
plan, some kind of roadmap,
that has some of the
right things on it.
And that's great news.
Because that wasn't the
case a couple of years ago.
But we're really finding is
where companies are stumbling
is around execution.
And while it's great
to say the right words,
it's got to have output
or it means nothing.
And so we're finding
that companies just
don't have the right
executive support-- again,
that APIs sound very geeky.
And they are not looking at
it across the organization
and at the brand level
enough, and they're not
thinking about
who's going to make
it, who's going to support it,
and who's going to consume it.
And therefore, that
nifty vision plan
and all those buzzwords that are
being put on the white boards
really amount to nothing.
It's even worse than
nothing, because it's
fooling the organization
into thinking
that they're transforming.
Now, another question I
get all the time is, Brian,
we've invested in ESP
technologies, SOA technologies.
So do we need this stuff?
I think we're OK.
And, you know, of
course you have.
I mean, that's
what everybody did
for the last 10 to 15 years.
But those are
integration technologies.
And the fact that your
integration technology
will allow you to do
some exposure actually
means nothing.
Exposure is not the problem.
Exposure is easy.
Taking a complicated
thing and moving it
one layer forward in the
architecture solves nothing.
If it's not being
consumed now, it's
not going to be consumed then.
This is all about consumption.
This is a new layer
in the architecture.
It generally sits in front of
the integration tier, the SOA
and ESB kind of tier.
This is the exposure
and consumption
layer with a heavy
focus on consumption.
Because when you
have transactions
flowing through
the system, that's
where your revenue comes from.
That's where delighted
customers come from.
When you have an API that
can be easily consumed,
treated as a product
not a project--
and think about all
the design implications
of a product versus a project.
We used to take photos
of doors every time
we visited a company around
the world, not the Jim Morrison
group, the actual doors on
the front of a building.
And what we noticed
is a lot of times
there would be like a pull bar
and a little sign that said
"push."
Now, if you know
how our brains work,
we have the lizard
brain that evolved
over millions and
millions of years,
and we have the frontal cortex,
which does verbal and is
very, very new.
And you know which
one wins when you
have bad design and a
little bit of documentation?
The lizard brain, every time,
right every single time.
And so you can't paper over
bad design with documentation.
That's what it means
to be a product,
is to think about
the affordance,
think about just by
looking at this API,
I understand how they
want me to use it.
Now, another mistake that I
see companies making is they
don't respect the
developers enough.
As much as I've
talked about this
as being a business level, high
level technology leadership
kind of issue, developers
are the kingmakers.
APIs are essentially invisible.
And if you don't have your
people, your contractors,
your digital agencies,
your third parties building
fantastic apps off of these
APIs, what's the point?
They're essentially invisible.
And then another
thing that I think
is difficult for
traditional companies
and traditional organizations
to get their heads around
is that minimum viable
is still viable.
So it's this idea, well, if we
don't have an 18-month project,
if we don't have these golden
magical requirements that
are somehow perfect
and will never change
and I believe don't
exist, how are we
ever going to produce anything?
But the idea is, if
we can get something
into the hands of
our users, especially
if it's an internal project--
so it's for some line of
business, some department--
the faster we get
things into their hands,
feedback about how
this is used in the real world.
And they say that no combat
plan survives contact
with the enemy, and I've found
the same thing about APIs
is that no API, no matter how
good your practitioners are,
no matter how much
you know about APIs
is no API survives first
contact with the developers.
You need to see how the
API behaves in the wild,
is consumed in the wild, to
really understand that API.
And as I mentioned earlier,
if it came down to one thing,
if I'm trying to convince my
colleagues about why we need
to be API first, why we
need to be API centric,
it's about speed.
It simply allows our different
departments and groups
to move faster.
It allows us to get ideas
into production faster.
It allows us to onboard
developers faster,
to onboard partners faster,
to onboard digital agencies
faster.
It allows us to look more
modern and more disruptive,
even if we consider
ourselves to be
a big, traditional
bureaucratic organization.
And then user
experience-- like I said,
it's not the muscle memory
of most traditional companies
to think in terms
of user experience.
We've tended to have kind
of a captive audience.
It's OK if we're a
generation or two
behind on the graphics
or the devices.
But it's really,
really important
to focus on the user experience.
People are voting with their
dollars, voting with the apps.
The revolution
wasn't the iPhone.
The revolution was the app
store a couple of months later.
That's how we live our lives.
That's where the revolution is.
I know this is kind
of a weird session.
It wasn't about installation.
It wasn't about configuration.
It wasn't about the code.
It wasn't about a live
demo of the product.
It was around all
those other bits
that go around it, but
unfortunately are just
as necessary to be successful.
And I want you all to have
very successful API projects
so I can tell great stories as I
fly around the world about what
you guys have done.
If you want to dig deeper,
we do have a few resources.
We have a micro site
dedicated to this topic.
And there's a brand new
hot-off-the-presses ebook about
how to stop thinking about APIs
as projects and start thinking
them as products.
Now with that said, I'm going
to pause here for a moment
and allow you guys time to put
any questions into the system
you'd like to put in.
And I'll be back
in just a second
to answer some of
those questions.
Thank you.
OK, everyone.
Thanks for staying with us.
We did get a couple
of questions.
I'd like to quickly
address those.
One question was, can we
configure Google Cloud
products, you know, some of the
existing Google Cloud products
and APIs such as BigQuery
or others using Apigee?
So the answer is yes, of course.
We have a lot of customers who
front many other backend APIs,
so various maps.
If you think about some of
the commerce applications,
some of the transaction
and settlement software.
A lot of those third party
APIs get fronted in Apigee.
So yes, of course, you're always
able to do any API, including
the Google Cloud APIs.
Now, the subtext
to this might be,
since Apigee is part
of Google Cloud,
is there some kind of
deeper integration?
And the answer is not yet.
But again, Google APIs are
so well-designed that it
is very easy to plug
Apigee in front of them.
It really doesn't take
a lot of work at all.
There's a few other
questions-- so
where does Apigee fit
into the architecture
that we already have?
Hopefully I convinced
you a little bit
that this is very different
than an integration technology.
You probably have ESB,
some SOA technologies.
And this would generally
sit in front of that.
And so Apigee is a great
bridge from legacy technologies
to the cloud technologies,
from legacy technologies
to modern apps, Android
and iPhone apps and things
like that.
And, you know, it
would generally
sit behind the firewall
on the load balancers
as one of the edge technologies.
That's what we
called it Apigee Edge
as it's meant to sit in front of
all those backend technologies.
And if you hit our website
or you ping us afterwards,
we'd be happy to do an
architectural deep dive.
And you can see some various
diagrams and white papers
where we go into this.
How do we start
focusing on consumption
instead of exposure?
This is dangerous, because
a lot of legacy vendors
are telling you, well, we've
added some bells and whistles
that allow you to do
exposure and make it
sound like that's the answer.
I was working at a
large telecommunications
company one day, doing a seminar
on API design best practice.
And they kept stumbling.
They were trying to
design their texting API,
write their SMS API.
And they kept having like
100 data fields in there.
And I kept saying to myself,
I'm not an expert in this field,
but it seems like you've got
a a sender, a time stamp,
content, and an
array of receivers,
so like four fields,
something like that?
I mean, whatever it is, it's
closer to four than it is 100.
And I said to them, why
do you think it's 100?
You're the experts,
but why is this?
And they said, well,
you know, we just
updated this system to 7.2.8.
Nobody cares.
Nobody should ever care or
know about that information.
With APIs, you've got to
think outside, not inside.
Somebody outside of
our organization,
outside of our
department, whatever,
what are they coming to us for?
Like, why do they come here?
Why do they come to us?
And make that as easy
to consume as possible.
Make your best goods on offer
as a super consumable API.
That's the way to start
think about consumption is
the other parts of the
business that come to us,
why do they come to us?
What's our core
offering for them?
Our customers, what's the
main reason they come to us?
How can I make that as easy
to consume as possible?
Instead of, what are the
advantages or limitations
of my backend systems or what
kind of version or vendor
I've got in my backend stuff?
And one question I get
all the time is, Brian,
you keep telling us not to
think of the APIs as a project.
Think of them as a product.
But we're starting
with a project.
Are we wrong?
Is this the wrong thing to do?
And of course not.
You often, in a
big organization,
will have a project that's
funded, that's staffed,
that has a charter,
that's on your portfolio.
That's great.
That's a perfect opportunity
to introduce these technologies
and introduce this
methodology, as long
as you're aware that this
goes well beyond that project.
APIs should be the center
of every project you do.
Your API platform should
span lines of business
and be across the entire brand.
As long as you go into
that single project
with that mindset,
you won't make those--
you know, I'm a lifelong
software architect.
Those 1,000 decisions that
you make, none of which
by themselves are critical,
but if you make them
all in the wrong
direction, you're
going to end up in a
very different outcome.
And so if you think of this
as not just for this project,
that this is the
future of the company,
then the project is a
great way to get started.
And to me, after these
kinds of sessions,
some people say, well, Brian,
I know you love linguistics,
you love language,
things like that.
Is this just fundamentally
a semantic issue?
And I truly don't believe that.
Any of you who have
built software,
which I assume is
most of you, know
that it's not just what
color the button is
and where it goes on the screen.
There are 1,000 questions
and design decisions
that we have to do along
the creation of a product.
And if we make all
those decisions
in a way that thinks
of this in a very
inside first traditional
20th century kind of mindset,
the result is going to be,
unfortunately, what we see all
over the app stores right now,
which is traditional companies
just kind of looking silly with
their apps, how far behind they
are graphically and usability.
And we're all frustrated.
We all have companies
that we're customers of
and we're frustrated
with their apps.
And why can't this be more like
some Silicon Valley startup's
fantastic, glamorous app?
And I think that's the harm.
I think the harm
is thinking that
what got you there
in the 20th century
is what's going to win in the
21st century, when empirically
we know that that's not true.
And so not focusing on the
experience, the customer
experience, not
focusing on speed,
not focusing on working
across organizational trust
boundaries, I don't think
that's semantic at all.
I think that fundamentally, like
statistically, will lead you
to situations that are conducive
to failing in the 21st century,
just as if you're API
centric, and you're
thinking of things in terms
of products and consumability
and customer experience.
It doesn't guarantee
success, but it
creates conditions that
are conducive to success
in the current digital
app-based, 21st century
marketplace that we
all have to compete in,
whether we like it or not,
in every region of the globe,
in every vertical.
We're all doing
business in 2018,
and this is simply what our
employees, our developers,
our partners, and our customers
have come to expect from us.
So I think that's all the
questions that we had.
And I know sometimes it's hard
when you're on the spot here
to think of a
question right now.
If you think one, when you're
taking a shower tomorrow
morning and, oh, I wish I'd
asked Brian this question,
feel free to ping us any time.
Reach out to us.
We'd be happy to talk.
We love talking
about this stuff.
We get very fired up
talking about this stuff.
And otherwise, we
hope that you'll
tune in next week, next Tuesday,
for the next Cloud OnAir
webinar.
My name is Brian Pagano.
I come to you from Google Cloud.
Thank you so much
for your time today.